hello everyone welcome to the data
analytics session building a global
marketing data hub on Google cloud
unpredictably data analytics specialist
with Google cloud in my role I support
and accelerate data analytics
initiatives across over retail and CPG
customers joining me today is pushing
mobile product manager on cloud Google
cloud data and analytics focusing on
cloud data fusion hey y'all excited to
be here so in this session we are going
to share how enterprises can build a
robust global marketing data warehouse
with Google cloud we'll talk about the
business needs and technical challenges
that enterprises encounter while
building a holistic marketing data
warehouses will then discuss cloudy
diffusion will be flour platforms data
ingestion and integration product and
how in delivers critical capabilities to
accelerate enterprise journey to
building marketing data warehouse will
also take you through a reference
architecture with Google Cloud products
that shows how easily and quickly you
can build marketing data warehouse in
Google's law finally we will close with
a recent case study of a CPG customer
who built their marketing data warehouse
with Google cloud platform today we want
to showcase how quick and easy it is to
build a marketing data warehouse using
Google cloud platform to draw in drive
your marketing analytics initiatives
with that let's get started marketing
data warehouses are becoming a critical
component of enterprises to accelerate
their marketing analytics initiatives
customer journeys have many touch points
an own customer or an unknown visit the
visitor they are all generating data
through interactions across channels and
devices like email websites applications
point-of-sale etc these touch points are
generating more data than businesses can
make sense of for instance visitors are
generating web traffic data wide
exposure data is collected across
multiple advertising systems CRM and
sales data is collected across multiple
systems as well having the consolidated
and holistic view of all of the data is
key to delivering enhanced customer
experience this requires organizing and
leveraging all the data enterprise's
have about customers across such modes
enterprises do recognize the value of
building a comprehensive marketing data
warehouse to solve their critical
business
NEADS so let's look at the business
needs that enterprises are trying to
address this marketing and data
warehouse first and foremost is customer
360 enterprises are seeking to build
customer 360 a source of truth record to
type all or almost all of touch points
together to fully understand customer
journey behaviors and preferences one
key challenge is data silos enterprises
have data silos in multiple databases
and systems all these systems and
databases are collecting diverse data
around customers and visitors all of
this data needs to be brought into a
single data warehouse to transform
before it can be made part of a single
customer 360 record capturing as much
information as possible around the
customer and its visitors the second key
point is personalization or the business
need is personalization meaning the
marketing data warehouses enable greater
level of personalization a stronger
understanding of the customer through
full view of all the touch points
provide greater capability to
personalize customers experiences such
as shopping browsing email marketing
etcetera consolidated data also provides
visibility into customer preferences
allowing enterprises to personalize with
higher accuracy and greater results
the third key business need is around
measurement enterprise's are leveraging
multiple software as a service or SAS
platforms for executing their marketing
and advertising campaigns such as email
display ads searches videos etc all of
these campaigns generate data on ad
exposure
collecting collecting campaign
performance data and feeding it back
into marketing data warehouse allows
enterprises to understand their campaign
performance and iteratively optimize
marketing and advertising campaigns the
fourth business need is around security
marketing data warehouses are also used
not just to ingest data from third-party
data providers but also to share data
back with such providers security is a
key need for building marketing data
warehouse since customers and visitor
data which sometimes is personally
identifiable information or PII is
shared between systems and platforms
data ingestion and export to third-party
systems should be highly secure as
customers have trusted enterprises with
storing and keeping their data safe safe
and the final business scene is around
machine
marketing data warehouses should be able
to connect to and leverage machine
learning products to build scalable
machine learning products such as
customer segmentation in lifetime value
of the customer purchase prediction
etcetera customer 360 data in marketing
data warehouses will allow data
engineering and data scientists to come
together to build machine learning
models for marketers that can be used
for activation across multiple platforms
so now we have seen that enterprises do
have a clear need for building marketing
data warehouses they quickly enter
counter a number of technology
challenges The Temper their ability to
move quickly and achieve these outlined
business needs so enterprises run into
these four key technology challenges
while building a marketing data
warehouse data silos software as a
service platforms integration data
integration needs and activation let's
look at each of these challenges one by
one
speaking of data silos data is
fragmented across multiple databases
certainly the sets are housed on prim
across databases and have existing
connections to bring the data in data is
also shared through different mechanism
for example for instance your vendor
might be providing data access through
API or lending that data on an FTP
server for you to pick up on a regular
schedule data below city also differs
across enterprises CRM and say this data
might be coming in as bad
whereas website visits might be coming
in entry near real time or real time
finally enterprises also use multi cloud
strategies so certain data sets might be
available on other public clouds or
on-premise systems the second technology
challenge is software as a service
platforms integration Enterprise is
leverage a number of marketing and
advertising platforms to set up and
execute their campaigns all of these
software is a service or SAS that from
scoid data ingesting and integrating
data from these multiple platforms
become a huge challenge since
enterprises have to set up siloed
integration points to get these data
sets into marketing data warehouse
managing and maintaining these silos
indications is also a major challenge
for enterprises
the third technology challenge is around
data integration was the data from
diverse systems databases and platforms
has landed there are clear requirements
for data integration data needs to be
wrangled and
form with sophisticated data pipelines
this step is also critical for building
customer 360 where enterprises are
looking to join multiple and and diverse
data sets around customer touch points
another example would be very
consolidated data needs to be aggregated
for marketer and executive reporting
finally data can be using wrangling and
transformation techniques to make it
easy for data science activities such as
model development and deployment and the
fourth technology challenge that we see
is around activation data in marketing
data warehouses is used for marketing
analytics initiatives such as
segmentation campaign reporting customer
modeling etc and these segments need to
be pushed back into SAS platforms for
creating and executing campaigns
leveraging the insights for marketing
data warehouse
similarly raw data is shared with
partners through multiple ways like SFTP
so all of these technology challenges
make it extremely hard to deliver
marketing data warehouse vision and its
benefit to marketers in this in the next
section we'll learn about how cloud data
fusion along with the Google cloud
platform products provide critical
capabilities that has enable customers
to build their marketing data warehouses
so for this section I will invite
pushing mobile product manager cloud
data fusion to take us through cloud
data fusion and its capabilities for
marketing data warehouse thanks buddy
let's get right into it and look at how
cloudy diffusion can help you address
some of these business needs and
technical challenges just that but it
just spoke about and help you build out
your own marketing data warehouse
quickly and easily on Google cloud
platform to get started data fusion is a
cloud native enterprise data integration
service on Google cloud it provides you
an end-to-end data integration
experience that allows you to ingest
prepare transform blend and enrich data
from various sources it helps you build
out your ETL and elt pipelines to curate
data leaks and it our warehouses on
Google cloud using a simple
point-and-click tree by using this you
can then focus on your business needs
your business logic and build out your
pipelines without having to
the intricacies of infrastructure and
integration this leader shows you an
overview of data fusions capabilities
with data fusion you can load data by
connecting to disparate data sources
such as relational databases file base
systems
modern real-time messaging systems
public cloud services as well as SAS
applications it provides you a
development studio in which you can drag
and drop sources transformations and
syncs to develop your data pipelines it
also includes capabilities to test
deploy run and monitor pipelines as well
as provides security and governance
controls for all data that gets
processed along the way diffusion is
built videos in an open source project
percy de serie is an extensible data
application framework which exposes
higher level business abstractions and
api is over complex technology using
which developers can build data
applications easy all along the way
taking advantage of the latest and
greatest of cloud infrastructure serie
then takes care of translating and
executing these applications which you
have created using your business logic
on to physical infrastructure it
consists of a core API and a runtime
data fusion is built as an application
of the Sira api for data integration use
cases data fusion exposes UI experiences
for ingesting wrangling integrating and
replicating data to end-users while
hiding the details of runtime and
execution environments from them
additionally it also contains specific
induct experiences for industry
verticals such as healthcare which can
take common data integration patterns
within specific industries users build
out their data integration pipelines
using these experiences and then they
can enter the rely upon data fusion to
figure out the best possible way to
execute them on physical infrastructure
on Google Cloud and others we never
having to worry about how that
underlying infrastructure works the key
value proposition here is that there is
a separation of design and
which allows you to play once and
execute in anywhere
currently data fusion executes spy
planes as MapReduce or spa programs on
cloud data proc more execution engines
such as state of loss data flow and
bigquery are on the roadmap however one
of the key aspects of data fusion
solution is to abstract these execution
engines away from the user and instead
provide an adaptive execution layer this
layer will then decide the appropriate
execution environment to use for a
pipeline based on inputs such as SLA and
cost that users can provide and T last
but not the least since like we decided
like we discussed all the processing
goes to a standard processing framework
data fusion can provide platform
capabilities such as security through I
am integration private access we see SEC
Mac etc as well as metadata and lineage
for all the data federated processes
with these enterprises can enable
largely self-service processing of data
with the right card rails that can
provide data protection and compliance
so let's look at some critical
capabilities within data fusion that can
allow you to easily and effectively
build a marketing data warehouse and
solve some of the business and technical
challenges that but they described
earlier the first one of these is code
free data integration so data fusion
provides a comprehensive data
integration toolkit which allows you to
build out your marketing data warehouse
in a portkey manner it includes a broad
range of connectors to common data
sources it provides a broad range of
point-and-click transformations that
allow you to prepare plans transform
blend and enrich data without ever
writing a single line of code
additionally since it is fully open
source and extensible you can also build
your own connectors for specific sources
as well as your own transformations with
just a few lines of code its seamless
integration with bigquery allows you to
load data into Google's industry-leading
cloud data warehouse easily and
effectively without having to worry
about understanding all the concepts
along with developing data pipelines
data fusion also provides critical
capabilities required for you to test
debug and operationalize your e ETL and
ELT pipelines in production environments
all of these capabilities allow you to
focus on deriving insights from your
data faster instead of struggling with
technology and integration thereby
significantly improving your time to
insight and production with these core
free data integration capabilities you
can easily build and curate your
marketing data warehouse by integrating
all your data regardless of its location
in addition to common data sources such
as relational databases and file systems
data fusion also contains connectors
that allow you to pull data from popular
CRM ERP social media and add tech
services which are critical inputs for
our marketing data warehouses it can
then transform and process the data
reliably and at scale using Google's
industry-leading processing engine such
as cloud 8 o'clock this takes away the
need for creating and maintaining
expensive bespoke point solutions and
scripts for loading data from each
source and ensure standardization and
governance along the way its seamless
integration with bigquery then allows
you to load data into Google's in the
shredder in cloud data warehouse with
just a few clicks another key aspect
here is data consistency so I can
discuss data fusion provides a
structured standardized framework for
transforming and processing your data
this brings in consistency in your data
processing change to better
traceability and governance which point
solutions and scripts can never provide
it gives you greater confidence in the
reliability of your data and and the
ability for you to make decisions out of
additionally the built-in data profiling
and quality checks increase your
confidence in the data that you value
another key aspect of all of this is
metadata so as data flows through data
fusion structured processing three-book
and the framework automatically connects
metadata about the
processes based off of this metadata
data feature can provide a
discoverability and lineage for all data
lineage to help you understand how the
data flows through your organization in
a visual manner P level lineage in data
fusion can provide a granular view of
the relationship between various fields
of datasets and the operations that are
performed on them this one box is cases
such as impact analysis of changes
before making them as well as root cause
analysis of data discrepancies and bad
events additionally metadata also
unlocks critical operational use cases
that help you understand and monitor
your datasets and also the processes is
that access or updater diffusion also
provides REST API is put it to you and
exchange lineage with other tools which
enables you to get a holistic end-to-end
view of your data processing another key
aspect of monitoring data warehouse is
data protection for which data fusion
provides the benefits of you know
classical data integration - but just in
a model cloud or TCP native be
integrated with the best security and
data protection standards that TCP has
to offer
it provides native security through
integration with cloud I am a network
security through private IP and VP CSC
encryption at rest using custom and
managed encryption keys sensitive data
management using cloud key management
service as well as data expectations and
positioning APCs
additionally it provides built-in
integration with data loss prevention
api's to mask redact and encrypt data in
flight right inside your pipeline with
just a few clicks so you no longer have
to worry about complex integration work
to protect your sensitive data your
diffusion is also compliant with popular
standards such as HIPAA PCI DSS sock and
ISO which are required in large security
conscious in printer prices the last of
the challenges that we need to address
is activation
we've seen so far how data fusions
capabilities and help you quickly build
out a robust marketing data warehouse in
between however that's usually not the
final goal for marketing data hub
but a critical step toward the goal once
you have curated your marketing data
warehouse you want to deliver the in
sites such as segments to target for a
campaign back to marketing platforms for
activation the diffusion provides
connectors that can help you regularly
push segments into popular process that
forms such a Salesforce marketing cloud
or segment or even share them securely
with third party providers or popular
targets such as SFTP and others this
removes the need for manual point
solutions and scripts for activation
that are hard to maintain and scale it
allows you to automate marketing
analytics pipelines end-to-end resulting
in increased efficiency and confidence
with that I will invite back ready to
take us through a classical example of a
sample marketing data warehouse and
itself is architecture that we had
recently done with a customer Thank You
Bhushan so let's look at the reference
architecture to build a marketing data
warehouse leveraging Google cloud
platform products specifically we love
data fusion in the center so we go from
left to right let's start with the data
sources location we have divided data
locations into four broad buckets
on-premise data public clouds
third-party data providers and
software-as-a-service platforms on Prem
systems in databases my toaster it hosts
a range of data sets such as CRM data
sales data etc as we said earlier
enterprises might be having multi tower
cloud footprint and some Vita sites
might be stored in other public clouds
then we have third-party data providers
that provide data enrichment services
and other data sets such as call center
blocks finally enterprises leverage
multiple advertising and marketing SAS
platforms to set up and execute
campaigns for display video email
etcetera these platforms provide either
raw or reporting level data for
enterprises for analysis so there are
two ways that we have shown here to
ingest these data sets first which is
noted in one in yellow cloud native
Fusion has a range of source plugins to
get the data ingested into the landing
zone which can be Google Cloud storage
if third-party data providers or SAS
platforms are providing the real-time
data you can leverage cloud pub/sub
which is moving clouds fully managed
real-time messaging
service that allows you to send and
receive messages between independent
applications once the data has landed in
Google Cloud Storage it can be used to
create a data pipeline with Cloud Data
fusion in number three as noted here
cloud a diffusion can be used to create
sophisticated data pipeline to join
aggregate and filter data to create a
consolidated and holistic marketing data
warehouse in bigquery which is Google
clouds fully managed server less data
warehouse that enables scalable analysis
over petabytes of data this architecture
is also supported by a horizontal set of
services to provide security logging and
monitoring capabilities cloud composer
boogie flouts fully managed workflow
orchestration service built on a patch
higher flow can be used to orchestrate
pipelines once the transformations have
been completed the curia query outputs
or tables can be pushed into multiple
systems or platforms for activation
using route data fusion starded or sync
domains for instance you might want to
push segments back into email marketing
platform for regular activation
marketing and advertising data processed
and stored in bigquery can also be used
for marketing and executed reporting
using business intelligence platforms
like loca so now let's look at a recent
case study so here we wanted to share a
case study for a global CPG customer the
customer wanted to build a global and
scalable marketing data warehouse to
drive their marketing analytics
initiatives specifically improving email
marketing KPIs by better understanding
their customer the customer had siloed
and fragmented data across multiple
systems databases and platforms the
database that is also included CRM
ecommerce web traffic
point-of-sale data they were also
getting data from a number of
third-party data providers that was used
to enrich their own first party data so
the goal of the initiative was to build
a 360 view of the customer with all the
data that they had and drive consistency
and standardization across their data
sets they also wanted to leverage
marketing data warehouse to execute
personalized and multi-channel campaigns
across a number of their advertising and
email marketing platforms finally they
wanted to ingest the campaign increases
back into marketing data warehouse to
understand the campaign and
personalization performance they've also
wanted to leverage the consolidated data
for their business intelligence
reporting needs so the customer
leveraged a modified version of the
reference architecture that we just
showed earlier to enable their marketing
analytics needs the leverage cloud data
fusion to ingest data from multiple
sources specifically from their email
marketing platform and data from
third-party data prove our third-party
providers the data was landed in Google
Cloud Storage from where it was used
with data prep for training before it
was pushed in to be liquid multiple data
pipelines were created using cloud data
fusion to automate the data ingestion
implication activities email marketing
campaign performance data was also
aggregated for reporting links once the
data was standardized and consolidated
in bigquery analysis was performed to
identify customer segments that they
wanted to push back into their email
marketing platform finally they created
pipelines using cloud data fusion to
push segments back into email marketing
platforms on a regular schedule for
activation the customer is now looking
at enhancing marketing data warehouse
further with additional forced and
third-party data sources with this
initiative the customer was able to
further improve their marketing KPIs
consolidated data and marketing data
warehouse enable them to deliver highly
personalized emails to their customers
resulting in double-digit growth in
email marketing KPIs
they were also able to build a holistic
customer journey combining multiple
touchpoints allowing them to deliver
improved
personalization across their media and
email marketing spend so in conclusion
we wanted to showcase in this session
how you can leverage Google cloud
platform specifically around data fusion
to build marketing data warehouse and
accelerate your marketing and
advertising initiatives thank you for
attending this session and we hope that
you will take this in size to your
organization and build your global
scalable marketing data warehouse with
Google cloud platform thank you